[Music]
this tiny plastic boat is floating
upside down in a layer of levitating
liquid
it looks like a gravity-defying magic
trick but in this case the magic is in
the science
and the mathematics behind this
counter-intuitive new phenomenon
to start with we need to explain how a
layer of dense liquid
can be suspended on a layer of less
dense air
the answer is vigorous vertical shaking
this part isn't a newly discovered
phenomenon though it can be tricky to
demonstrate
take this dense blue liquid in a glass
container
when you flip it upside down it starts
to fall due to gravity
it doesn't just move down all in one
mass though
like paint falling down a wall it starts
to drip
the bottom surface bulges into droplets
which fall
displacing the air underneath until it
ends up all in a layer at the bottom
as you'd expect but if you place the
container on a shaker
set to a suitable frequency something
unusual happens
once the blue liquid is fully upside
down it stops
dripping the vibrations prevent
the droplets from forming and keep the
whole bottom layer of the liquid
nearly flat and if the droplets
can't form the liquid can't fall
it's floating on a trapped cushion of
air
contained by the glass on either side
it's compressing the air below it
but it can't displace it so it hovers
in place while this was already known
researchers in france have been
exploring another even more
counter-intuitive effect of the shaking
they place a boat or a light plastic
ball
at the bottom surface of the liquid it
floats
in place just like it would at the top
surface
this is partly because the air pressure
underneath the ball is quite high
since the air is being compressed by the
weight of the liquid pressing down on it
but as you go up the liquid layer the
pressure decreases
as there's less water above it pushing
down
[Music]
this results in the ball or boat being
pushed up
by the pressure underneath that is until
it reaches an equilibrium point
where that upwards force is balanced out
by the downwards force of gravity
and it floats this balance of forces is
what
causes buoyancy and that's exactly
what's happening here too
albeit upside down
but the most puzzling thing about this
upside down floating effect
is that it's stable if you gently push
or pull the boat
it'll bob back to its equilibrium
position just like its right side up
counterpart does on the surface
the researchers mathematically modeled
the forces involved
and sure enough the figures predict this
bizarre
stable reversed buoyancy it may seem
contradictory to all common sense
but the maths checks out
the effects does depend on the system
being shaken hard enough though
and at the right frequency if the
vibrations get too small and gentle
the ball and the liquid will eventually
fall
but get the shaking right and that is
how science
can lead to a boat floating upside down
on a levitating layer of liquid
not with magic but with maths